hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor make sure you check out the
link in the description box below
to go to a folder that has a bunch of
free
pdf study notes
i will drop a picture of the final board
in that folder so you can have a picture
of the final board to study from today
we're going to talk about xld auger make
sure that you also know that i have a
micro diagnostic test playlist i think
it's called microbiology diagnostic
tests but it has all kinds of tests you
know the catalase test the coagulase
test it has a bunch of
differential augers it has a bunch of
different videos about different
microbiology stains that you'll do in
lab so if you're taking a microbiology
lab course please please please check
out that video they're so
or that playlist i mean there's so many
great videos for you there
okay so let's talk about xld auger xld
stands for xylose lysine deoxycholate
now you should recognize here that
xylose
ends in oats so it's a sugar so it's a
type of sugar just like sucrose or
fructose but it's got a different
structure
and then lysine is one of our amino
acids and then we've got deoxycolate in
there as a different chemical compound
so that's what the xld stands for
now xld auger is both selective and
differential let's talk about what this
means selective means that it allows for
the growth of some types of organisms
while inhibiting the growth of other
types of organisms in this case xld
auger is selective because it contains a
bile salt
sodium deoxycolate that's also where
part of the name comes from sodium
deoxycolate it's a bile salt
and that inhibits
gram
positive
bacterial growth so basically
gram-negative bacteria will be able to
grow gram-positive bacteria will be
inhibited
if you need a refresher on the
difference between gram-positive and
gram-negative cell walls check out my
video on that topic
now xlb auger is also differential that
means that of the stuff that is able to
grow on xld auger
there will be
differences in their usually color
some kind of phenotypic difference so
that you can distinguish
one thing from another and in this case
what xld auger is helping you to
distinguish
is shigella
from salmonella
now
there will be some other types of things
that can grow as well some other types
of coliforms and we'll talk about them
in a minute but when xld auger is being
used in a micro lab it's typically to
distinguish shigella from salmonella or
to see if one of these is present in a
sample
now also present in xld auger is yeast
extract this is a sort of a complex
media right with that yeast extract
yeast extract is used because it adds
nitrogen amino acids carbon vitamins
basically the things that shigella and
salmonella and other coliforms need to
grow
it also has phenol red now phenol red is
an indicator
so as an indicator the media is
initially going to be
red
okay so phenol red
is red at this ph about 7.4
but
if there is fermentation going on so
fermentation of xylose or one of the
other sugars we're going to talk about
over here if there's some kind of
fermentation happening
the colonies that are able to ferment
the sugar
and produce an acid right that will
lower the ph
and the colonies themselves
will turn
yellow
okay so initially the media is red and
then if there's fermentation happening
you're going to see yellow colonies
now let's talk about shigella and
salmonella
these are the two that we are using xld
auger to distinguish between
shigella species this spp right there
means species multiple shigella species
they cannot use xylose okay
they also cannot use at least not very
well lactose and sucrose so we'll get to
those later but they can't use the
xylose that the salmonella can use
and so they will grow as red colonies
so shigella on xld media grows as red
colonies with no black centers that's
going to be important later so no black
centers just plain red colonies
now let's talk about salmonella
salmonella is a lot more complex
salmonella first of all will rapidly
ferment that xylose sugar so it will
ferment the xylo sugar
with an acid product and this will turn
the colonies yellow as we said right
here turn the colonies yellow lowering
the ph that phenol red indicator
then kicks in and you've got a yellow
color
but then you know this happens pretty
rapidly
so then salmonella will
decarboxylate lysine now that is because
salmonella has an enzyme
lysine decarboxylase shigella lacks that
enzyme but salmonella has the lysine
decarboxylase it can decarboxylate
lysine
once the xylose is exhausted once it's
already used up all the xylose and this
decarboxylation of lysine will produce
amines and of course amines are basic or
alkaline so they will raise the ph and
so those colonies that were once yellow
are going to turn
red
now at this point you might be saying
wait hold on how can we distinguish
shigella from salmonella if they both
are making red colonies
well the really the the distinguishing
factor here is that the xld auger along
with the xylose and the lysine and the
deoxycolate and the and
the yeast extract and the phenol red
there's a lot of stuff in this agar it
also has a hydrogen sulfide indicator
system i'm going to put some stars here
because this is really how we're going
to be able to distinguish shigella from
salmonella
now what is this uh hydrogen sulfide
indicator system it involves sodium
thiosulfate and ferric ammonium citrate
and together these things when there is
hydrogen sulfide production
it gives
black
centers
on the colonies
and only salmonella
is capable
of
uh producing the hydrogen sulfide
so
shigella will make red colonies
salmonella will make red colonies with
black centers
now there are a couple of other sugars
in addition to all the other ingredients
we've talked about there's also lactose
and sucrose present and these are here
to prevent false positives so let me
explain lactose and sucrose are present
in large quantities okay large
quantities large concentrations
they are there
to be metabolized
by other coliforms
think other coliforms like e coli for
example so other coliforms that may also
be present in the sample
these other coliforms prefer
lactose and sucrose
over
lysine so they will use lots of lactose
and sucrose that's there in such large
quantities
and they will result in
yellow colonies
so these sugars basically prevent these
other species from using the lysine and
causing
a false positive
for
salmonella
make sure that you again check out this
playlist right here lots of videos on
many different differential and
selective augers as well as other
microbiology diagnostic tests so check
it out grab the picture of the final
board so you can study it in the link in
the description box below and thank you
for watching biology professor see you
guys next time